foreign
is with us in St Louis Aiden get me out
of this how can we help
doing all right how's it going better
than I deserve man how can we help
yeah so um I took a weekend trip to
Texas and I messed up and bought a car
while I was there are you drinking
um no I just I saw the car before I went
down there and it's my dream car and I
just messed up and ended up doing it now
I can't get the thought out of my head
that I could be using that money for a
down payment on a house what car was it
and how much did it cost you
uh the car was 20 000 and it's a 2013
Nissan 370Z what's the payment on that
uh my total payment works out to around
450 a month
okay
and what were you driving before
a 2002 Honda Accord with 275 000 miles
and it's broke in on me like four times
in the past two months how'd you get to
Texas
um I just went with my buddy okay so you
still got the Accord
yeah
how old are you
19.
okay
um
and and what's your question sir
just don't I just don't know if I should
keep the car and deal with it because I
and pay the stupid taxes you say because
I know I messed up
or what to do from here because I
I mean I can afford I mean I can afford
the payment and you know between me and
my fiance we make enough money or it's
not exactly a big Financial strain on us
but I just can't shake that idea of the
down payment on a house there's not an
us you're not married
yeah well so we get married uh in a
month from now oh okay so you just
saddled her with a car payment instead
of a house yeah I bet she's happy
she kind of told me she thought that I
deserve to have something at least kind
of nice but she said she's gonna we're
gonna work as it on it as a team
together what's your income now and
what's your income going to be when
you're married
so my income now is about 3 500 bucks a
month
um through my night job and then I just
got my real estate license at the end of
last year
um and then she makes around three three
thousand dollars a month and so it'll be
around 6 500 bucks a month without
without anything from Real Estate
um
wow can I ask what other debt you have
in between with her as well
neither of us have any other debt other
than this I've got
um I personally I have a little bit of
cash about around three three months
worth of expenses I've got six thousand
in a Roth 2500 in mutual funds and this
is like my first ever mess up
potentially and then she has around 20K
cash with no investment okay I want you
to tell her I said this okay
okay you don't deserve the car she's
wrong
if you deserved it you would have had
the money to pay for it
you don't deserve 450 car payments
you're not that bad a guy
yeah you don't deserve hell
okay so I'm not gonna you know know you
know your deserve something when you
have saved the money and you pay for it
until then you don't deserve it
that was a that's a childish statement
and if you if you repeat that statement
over and over you're going to be broke
your whole life
yeah
I deserve it now that's McDonald's I
deserve a break today you're gonna
deserve a Big Mac that's the best you
can do
seriously so uh what would I do if I
woke up in your shoes is I would sell
the car because you have cost your
family the down payment and I would get
rid of it and you made a mistake you
impulsed and um you made a
uh and and the other thing Aiden that uh
I do when I pay stupid taxes I want to
do an autopsy and a CSI
on the situation and go okay what was
going on that allowed me to be this
stupid
was it was it your buddy yes
I think I was just with my friends and I
just really wanted I just wanted a nicer
car because my car you know what what
process is going on in your life what
process is going on in your spirit in
your intellect in your decision-making
Paradigm that allows you to make this
bad decision you know you want to know
that so you don't do it again right
yeah because I think it's if you impulse
20 000 items and your fiance says I you
deserve it you're you're going to be
broke your whole life man and so the bad
news is you made a mistake the good news
is you're only 19 and you have the whole
rest of your life to never impulse a car
again yeah you might do some other dumb
things but let's take that one off the
table this is the last time you're gonna
do this one check never do that one
again because it's going to cost you
some money by the time you get out of it
you're probably not even going to get
out of it without writing a check right
and so it's going to set you back but I
I wouldn't
I would get rid of it because of how it
occurred
well he's never going to be able to even
he's never going to be able to enjoy the
car because of the way he feels about
how he purchased it he's it's it's
always going to be that burden to him
feels like he's got a financial hangover
right yeah
yeah I'd sell it too I mean numbers wise
they could probably make it work but
it's I think it's a principle here and
it's honestly it's how they're setting
their marriage off and that's not the
foot I'd want to set it off I I
I think I'm admitting that what I did
was a bad idea by getting rid of it I
think by keeping it in some way you're
endorsing this saying some portion of
the decision was a good decision right
right and honestly none of it was yeah
so I think it's a it's not really about
the car and it's not even about twenty
thousand dollars with their you know
with their eighty thousand dollar income
it's more about I've got to make sure my
brain never works this way again because
it didn't work well yeah when I was
doing this and you're the sum of the
people you hang around I just want to
throw that out there
sounded like whoever he was with isn't
it had an influence on him being an
idiot yeah because yeah if you're gonna
listen if if you run around with your
drinking buddies you're gonna have a
drinking problem heck yeah this is how
it works I mean this is not you become
who you hang around with that's right so
you just gotta you gotta watch this
stuff it's uh
yeah I'm I'm
uh I want to be hard not on you Aiden
because you made a mistake that almost
everyone in America has made it one time
or another in their lives but I do want
to be very very hard on
the actual event I want to be very hard
on the way your brain was working during
that event so that you don't re repeat
right and you don't have to live with
this kind of pain that you know when
Sharon and I went broke Aiden and we
lost everything we were 28 years old we
had a brand new baby and a toddler and a
marriage Hanging On by a thread
one of the benefits of having gone broke
at that age and lost a million dollar
net worth lost four million dollars
worth of real estate is I got the
opportunity to repeatedly do what you're
doing or what I'm asking you to do and
that's doing autopsy on my stupidity you
know okay what killed the patient
why did he die you know is it what's the
comorbidity I mean we know it was
covered but what's the comorbidity right
so comorbidity it had to be covered it's
everything's coveted but we you know but
he but it's never mind the fact they get
run over by a car when he had covered
but he died of covet you know but let's
really get to looking at what really
really happened here
with the patient why did the patient
expire why did I make this stupid butt
decision and I had to unpack that and I
spent
actually a year or more unpacking that
so that I never went back again right
and thus was born what we teach every
day
so there you go